tell me about your best night in college
my best night at College yeah okay wow
my buddy and I were drunk at the zoo
and if you were there near closing time
there's like around six or seven New
Hampshire
we're walking around we're making fun of
animals and
uh and we get to the Rhino pack
and my buddy goes look at that
I said no no no you this this animal has
a sword on its face
[Music]
they don't make you with a sword on your
face if you're scared of people
let me says to me
twenty dollars
so that I don't jump in the pack with a
bun now in college in the 90s 20 is 10
beers
that's a lot do you know what I'm saying
and so I was like 20 bucks you don't
jump up the bed you get 20 bucks and he
goes 20 more bucks if I touch it on the
ass foreign
[Music]
and it was a long rectangular pen it was
at the end of the pen behind a wooden
fence and it was a fence and had an
opening big enough for the reminder to
get out right so
he now this dude he was wearing jeans
tied them on uh he jumps in one of these
Wranglers he said cowboy boots on he's
got his little five
dude from West Texas his name is Jack
and by the way he is now a heart surgeon
now the Rhino pen is a the walls are
cement walls it's not like there's steps
up and down so he grabs on the side and
he just lets go and he drops it I bet
you the wall is probably nine and a half
ten feet
maybe a little less Maybe
and so he starts to walk up to the right
line
and he's walking up to me doing and he's
turning to me so he'll turn around he's
doing something I guess
and the Rhino's not moving
and for a second I was like
do I not know what rhinos
like why isn't this rhino sticking his
horn up this dude's [__]
this is what we're paying the money for
you know what I mean
[Music]
it's getting closer and closer with not
care in the world I mean what is
happening he probably got Within
feels like 15 feet
and the Rhino just looked at him
and let out this noise I'd never heard
noise
I was like oh that's what a real animals
thank you
and my bunny turned to me
and I was like
there's the fear I'm looking for
let's do straight up
realize so I made a big mistake
and the Rhino turns and it's not that
Nimble right but when it gets out the
hole yo I'll tell you something right
now rhinos are faster than I thought
they were
and I was like oh this is going to be
close
and I reach my hand down
and I go come on man I'm gonna grab my
hand and the Rhinos
guys by the way
I wish I had a picture with his voice
but you've never seen fear until you see
till you see them chased by a rhino
the fear that you need to use back to
ever unlock you know what I'm saying
that's deep dark
he runs he puts one jumps One Foot In
The Wall grabs my hand all of my weight
I just whole
lift him up out of that pen I want to
tell you how close it is dude I've
lifted him up the Rhino was so close to
him the Rhino ran into the wall
rhinos don't stop on a bag
they don't really have breaks you know
what I mean this dude
into the water
my body's laying there
out of breath
just not saying anything I'm laying
there laughing my ass oh my God I almost
saw you die right now you're like you're
right almost split you in two bro
[Music]
and we're walking out of the zoo quiet
he has a set of words
and then he looks at me and he goes
hippo not Rondo hippo
I don't know
I like to smoke weed bring it I like to
smoke weed
I like to smoke weed bring it
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]